- (commentateur): Robinson à
(exclamation de la foule)- - - d
ont été une source d'inspiration
ceux du groupe Loco Locass.
♪ ("Le but" de Loco Locass) ♪
SÉBASTIEN FRÉCHETTE "BIZ",
- C'est quelqu'un,
effectivement, qui a transcendé
son sport, qui l'a chargé
d'une charge symbolllllllllllllr
peut se reconnaître.
- ♪ Un autre Démon blond
fait son apparition ♪
- Des chansoagagagagagagagagaga.
Dans "Boule à mites",
Daniel Boucher a chanté
le Guy Lafleur de son DANIEL BO,
auteur-compositeur-ièèèète
- ♪ Lafleur,
derrière son filet ♪
de ma passion pour le hockey et.
Ça a commencé le fameux soir
du septième match contre Bosti .
- Icône culturelle, le numéro 10
a aussi inspiré des artistes
visuels comme Serge Lemoyne,
récemment exposé au Mueaeaeaeaee
Québec.sesesesesesesesesesesesee
de l'art contemporain, MNBAQ
- Guy Lafleur c'était l'idole
en fait de cette génération.
- Au sommet de sa popularité,
Guy Lafleur s'est aussi fait
un disque de disco prodiguant
des conseils de hockey.
tes pieds, ajoute un peu de
rebondissements.eueueueueueueuer
"Les yeux de Maurice Richa
- Aujourd'hui, c'est pas
un sportif, évidemment
mais, c'est normal!
C'est ça, son univers culturel.
- Celui qui a remporté cinqe e f
en jouant au petit écran,
comme icmimimimimimission
"Chez Denise".
- 'Scusez moi, M. Lafleur!
Si j'avais su!
tu l'avais pas reconnu!
- On l'a aussi vu dansenenenene.
- Lafleur means "the flower".
- Est-ce que je peux inviter
mon ami Guy à soupe
- Bonjour.
- Ah... bonjour!
- Je dois vous avouer une chose,
j'ai pas vu passer...
- Adulé par tousi i i i i i i it
au coeur. Il y a moins d'un an,
il était ému aux larmes
devant cette nouvelle sculpture
de l'aauauauauauauauauauauauaua.
GUILLAUME TARDIF, artiste
- C'est le genre de personne
qui inspire plusieurs artistes,
à vouloir marquer dans l'espace
et dans le temps le passage
de cette personne-là.- Guy Lafls
dans nos mémoires. D'ailleurs,
un film sur sa vie pourrait
voir le jour en 2023.
- Je connais personne
qui n'aime pas Guy Lafleur.
- Moi, de le voir décoller,
à l'aile droite, puis décocher,
pour moi, ça, c'est une image
immortelle.
- Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
(acclamations de l